[Music]
foreign
so it's good to be back I'm really
excited about this lecture where we are
going to expand the differential
equations we've been solving to include
forcing terms so instead of just x dot
equals a x we're going to add the effect
of some external forcing or disturbance
on the system
and so the forcing could be
um it could be a disturbance it could be
a control so this forcing
uh could be
could be a control input
or a disturbance
to your system
but we think of it as something that is
kind of external to the intrinsic
dynamics of the system and this is going
to connect what I've been telling you
about differential equations to control
theory which is a huge and important
area so one of the reasons we love
dynamical systems and differential
equations is because it allows us to
model and control the real world so this
is going to be how we we transition into
that vast literature on control theory
and I have a whole controlled boot camp
so once you kind of know how this works
you're going to be able to access all of
that controls knowledge
okay good
um and so the kind of differential
equation we have been talking about up
until now is something like uh X double
dot I'm going to pick a really easy
example plus three x dot
plus two x equals zero and this is known
as a homogeneous differential equation
because the right hand side is equal to
zero there's no forcing there's no
disturbance on this system so we're
going to call this uh homogeneous or
homogeneous homogeneous if you like
um
and these are the kinds of systems we
have been solving up until now is simple
linear differential equations uh with no
forcing so you could write this as a
matrix system and solve that or you
could solve this using the
characteristic equation we know lots and
lots of ways of solving this so I'll put
that there's an asterisk that's you know
equation one and what I'm going to tell
you about today is the kind of
generalization of this where we take the
same Dynamics X double dot plus 3 x dot
plus 2X but now we're going to set this
equal to some forcing term some f of x
and we're going to call this as you
might have guessed inhomogeneous in
homogeneous
inhomogenous sounds weird to me so I'm
going to say inhomogeneous uh get those
little extra vowels and and consonants
and syllables in there inhomogeneous and
so this is what we're going to be
talking about how do we solve the same
differential equation but where we have
this inhomogeneous forcing term and
again that forcing could be something
external maybe this is a model for
how plants grow and this is the solar
cycle and I just I know that it's kind
of a sinusoidal cycle or something like
that and so I just plug that in or maybe
it's an external control variable it's
something I actually have control over
that I'm going to use to manipulate the
behavior of the system so both of those
are are valid
um
good and there are going to be two
fundamental approaches I'm going to use
to show you how to solve this kind of
inhomogeneous forced ordinary
differential equation
the first method which I'm going to talk
about today is called the method of
undetermined coefficients so method one
which is what I'm going to talk about
today is the method of undetermined
coefficients undetermined
coefficients
basically it's a fancy way of saying
we're going to guess the answer and then
figure out a coefficient out front that
makes that guess work
um and Method two
which is much more powerful but a little
bit Messier is called variation of
parameters variation
of parameters
and variation of parameters is going to
work for a broader class of functions f
of x and it's also going to be
essentially when we solve partial
differential equations later using the
Laplace transform
we're going to get
Odes whose Solutions are those
coefficients out front of the solutions
those constant one and constant two
those are actually going to be transfer
functions and we're going to use the
method of variation of parameters
potentially to solve for those but today
I'm going to talk about
method one the undetermined coefficients
today and in the next lecture I'll move
on to the variation of parameters and
this is a pretty simple idea maybe I'll
make this even more concrete I'll say
you know an example
an example uh f of x
sorry this is not f of x this is f of T
um really really important uh for me to
be extra clear here this is a forcing
which is a function of time this is D DT
of X and the forcing is a function of
time okay so in that solar example of a
plant growing and this is the Solar
Dynamics that would be the solar
intensity as a function of time that
sinusoidal not a function of X and my
control variable is something that at
each instant in time I get to decide
what what that F of T is okay so sorry I
should have made this that was a typo so
in this example our F of T we're just
going to pick something really easy
which is like an exponential function or
a sine or a cosine here I'm going to
pick e to the minus 3 t
and
I'm going to give kind of a teaser we
know that if this forcing is something
simple like an exponential function or a
sign or a cosine it's probably going to
be easier to solve because we know that
this the generic solution of
differential equations is given by
exponentials and Sines and cosines so
this method here of undetermined
coefficients is going to work
particularly well and it's going to be
easy when this forcing is one of those
simple building blocks of a linear
system an exponential function or a sine
or a cosine and when it's something much
more General and nasty you're probably
going to need variation of parameters
okay if that's just heads up okay so
this is the example and then the last
bit of information you're going to need
are the initial conditions which I'm
going to say x of 0 equals 2 and x dot
of 0 equals minus four we may or may not
need these depending on how far we get
with this derivation
and so
um this
solution to the inhomogeneous uh
ordinary differential equation it's
actually really really simple there's
kind of three simple steps and they all
build on exactly the same kind of thing
we've been doing for all of these
lectures on how to solve this
so the first step and this one is
completely review is part one we solve
the homogeneous equation so I'll just
literally write this in parts so part
one or step one part one
uh is that we solve the homogeneous
equation
so solve
the
homogeneous
equation
which is asterisks equation asterisks
okay and so we kind of know what the
solution of this is I can compute the um
maybe I'll just write down the
I'll write down the characteristic
equation it's
Lambda squared plus 3 Lambda plus two
equals zero which implies that Lambda
plus 2
times Lambda plus one equals zero I'm
just factoring this out and so Lambda
equals minus one and Lambda equals minus
two are my eigenvalues easy peasy right
so we solve the homogeneous equation
and we basically have that the solution
is X of t
equals some constant e to the minus t
plus another constant e to the minus 2T
okay we know how to do this and we don't
know what these constants are if it was
if there was no forcing if F of T was
Zero we would solve for these
coefficients using our initial data our
initial conditions here
but we're not going to do that just yet
because we still have to take into
account this this inhomogeneous forcing
term okay so that was step one part two
step two
is now we're going to solve for what is
called the particular solution which is
a solution some function that you can
plug into here that will equal F of t
Okay so the homogeneous solution solves
this equation equals zero the particular
solution is going to solve this equation
equals F of t so now what we're going to
do is find a particular solution find a
and this is literally called it's not
just a particular solution it's called
the particular Solution that's what it's
called in math a particular solution
and I'm probably going to call this like
um X subscript P or something like this
uh to asterisks asterisks we're solving
the particular solution to the double
star equation
um
by assuming
that this particular solution x p of T
is equal to what we're going to assume
is that it's going to have the form of
this forcing term this e to the minus 3T
and notice that neither of my two
homogeneous uh Solutions e to the minus
t or e to the minus 2T neither of those
look like an e to the minus 3T so this
is you know a different kind of term
than either of these I can't build this
as a linear combination of these so
we're going to do is assume that our
particular solution has this form but it
has some constant out front and I don't
know what that constant is so we're
going to assume that this is you know
some k e to the minus 3T
uh and then we're going to plug that in
to this equation and see what that
constant is that will make this thing
equal zero okay so I literally can just
compute the derivative x p dot equals
minus 3 k e to the minus three t
x p double dot is plus nine
k e to the minus 3 T and so if I combine
all of those together all of that
information I have that
if I plug in my particular solution here
I get 9k
plus 3 times minus 3 K is minus 9 k
plus 2 XP is plus 2K
all of that times e to the minus 3T
that's everything on the left hand side
that has to equal my forcing term F of T
which was e to the minus 3T
and now I hope you're kind of seeing why
we guessed that the particular solution
had this form because we know that if if
our particular solution has this form if
I take its first derivative and its
second derivative it will still be of
the form e to the minus three T and so
by choosing this constant K carefully
I'll be able to find this particular
solution that if I plug it in all of
these terms will add up exactly to equal
e to the minus 3T
and so I think that means
this out here is just something like 2K
e to the minus 3T equals e to the minus
three T which implies that you know 2
times k equals one so k equals one half
so my particular solution is literally
one half e to the minus three T that's
my particular solution for this problem
okay so that was part one solve the
homogeneous equation part two find the
particular solution part three
um is kind of neat part three what you
do is you combine these two solutions
because these are both this is a
solution of my differential equation
that satisfies this equals zero
this is a solution of my differential
equation that satisfies this equals zero
and this is a solution of my
differential equation that satisfies
this equals F of T and so those are all
Solutions in my differential equation
and I can take a linear combination of
those and those are still a solution of
my differential equation this is the
fundamental property of linearity these
are linear differential equations and so
superposition holds if I have two
solutions then I can add those up and
those are still a solution and so this
is really important is essentially if I
take my homogeneous Solutions and I add
those to my inhomogeneous solution they
still satisfy this blue equation here so
I can add this constant here to this
term and when I take the derivatives of
this of this pink term they add up to
zero so they don't mess up
you know this this blue term also being
a solution so this blue term plus this
red this pink term are also Solutions
because if I take the derivative of the
sum of all three of these terms these
add up to zero and this still adds up to
F of T so that whole solution adds up to
F of t Okay
um and so that's that's really important
is that the full solution so I'll write
this down part three
uh part three
is to add up
all three terms
and so that gives me something like
maybe I'll just write this uh
you know in blue X of T equals uh C1 e
to the minus t
plus C2 e to the minus 2T plus this one
half
e to the minus 3 T and notice that this
doesn't have just an arbitrary constant
out front of it we determined this K
constant has to be one half to satisfy
this exact forcing term e to the minus
three T this inhomogeneous forcing term
so every solution has to have this term
in it to add up to equal f
and then that solution can have any
constant e to the minus t plus any other
constant e to the minus two t and this
is definitely a solution
you know right now if you wanted to you
could pause the video and you could take
this expression here and you could
compute its first derivative and its
second derivative and you could plug it
into this equation and convince yourself
that these two terms here from the
homogeneous solution
they add up and they don't change this F
of T they don't they don't mess up this
equaling F of T and because we have this
term here the solution definitely adds
up to equal F of T so any of any uh X of
T of this form will solve this equation
and part of this last step now is you
can determine these coefficients
uniquely using your initial conditions
just like we would before
but when we do that we have to solve for
these uh you in this equation that has
all three terms not in this equation up
here that only has two terms because our
solution has this extra inhomogeneous
term here this extra term it's going to
kind of change these coefficients needed
to satisfy these initial data so let's
just confirm okay so X of 0 if I plug in
0 to this solution now I have that
equals C1 plus C2 plus one half
and that equals 2.
and x dot
evaluated at zero I'm just going to read
it off because x dot is minus C1 plus
minus two c two dot plus minus three
halves e to the minus this so I can just
read this x dot off that's minus C1
minus 2 c 2 minus three halves equals
minus four
and again I chose these initial
conditions to be easy to um to kind of
evaluate this so if if constant one is
one half and constant two is one then
both of these are satisfied so C1 equals
one half and C2 equals one
but notice that I had to use this
expression that had all three terms
after I found my particular solution I
had to have my particular solution to
evaluate X of 0 and x dot of 0 because
that term is going to add this one half
or this minus three halves to those so I
need to have this particular solution in
my expression before solving for these
coefficients using my initial conditions
I can't solve for my constants using my
homogeneous solution I need to have that
particular solution in there too because
that affects my X naught and my x dot
not
okay that's it that's the that's the
method of undetermined coefficients it's
super easy
um you write down you know uh you solve
the homogeneous part of the equation
then you guess that there will be an
extra term that looks like you're
forcing but it has an undetermined
coefficient so you plug that into the
equation you solve for that constant k
then you add up all of those terms and
you use those uh to find your your
coefficients with your initial
conditions
a good example for you to do
would be
um you know so so if these are simple
exponentials it's pretty easy you just
guess that exponential another good
example would be to try you know what if
this equals something like
um you know cosine of Omega T so I have
some some forcing at some frequency cos
Omega t
now when I when I try to solve for my
particular solution you're going to your
XP
of T we know that the things that are
going to the the functions X of t
where that function and its derivatives
look like cos Omega T are going to be
things like cosines and Sines right
because the first derivative of cosine
is going to be a sine the second
derivative is going to be cosines again
so in my method of undetermined
coefficients if my forcing is a cosine
I'm going to need to actually have some
constant a
cosine Omega t plus some constant B sine
Omega t okay and you're going to
essentially uh plug this whole thing
into your expression here and then
you're going to solve for A and B so
that that all adds up to equal cos Omega
T so that's actually a really good
exercise for you is do this exact same
procedure but assuming that F of T
equals cos Omega T and in this step here
where we assume the particular solution
has this form try it out first off try
it out with just a cosine Omega T you'll
realize that something goes wrong and
then try it with a COS Omega t plus b
sine Omega T and then you'll be able to
determine that set of of particular
Solutions you'll add them up now you'll
have four terms because you'll have a
plus a COS Omega t plus b sine Omega T
and you'll use that to find your your
constants with with your initial data so
that's a really good exercise to make
sure you understood how this all worked
is to try it with f of T equals cos
Omega t with this particular solution
okay in the next lecture I'll show you
how to do variation of parameters so
that's coming up next thank you
[Music]